Welcome to.
Now you see it.
Disney films have made great strides in
their portrayal of women from the
entirely domestic and dependence snow
white in 1937 Oh
to the adventurous and unconstrained
Maretta in 2012 a princess just not
please her weapons on the team.
It's hard to go a single day on the
Internet without finding yet another
blog post about free spirited women in
Disney movies,
especially the Disney princesses.
They all praised Disney movies for
making great steps towards women's
rights in our society.
But who cares?
These are just movies.
Shouldn't we stop relying on fictional
storytelling to comment on reality?
I want to argue the film is in fact,
one of the best methods of commenting on
a society and a Disney princess can have
more influence on the society than any
politician or leader women.
Every popular film to some extent
conforms with the society.
It was maiden.
Think about it.
If a movie was released this year that
generalized all African Americans as
unintelligent and sexually aggressive
towards women and also made out the Klu
Klux Klan is heroes,
would it be a commercial success?
Probably not that wouldn't conform to
the values of our present society,
but in the early 19 hundreds this kind
of film could be a critical hit because
that's society conform to those beliefs.
And it was in 1915 the birth of a nation
was released and became the highest
grossing film of the year despite
generalizing African Americans as
unintelligent.
And the KKK is heroes.
What I'm saying is people don't like
seeing movies that greatly contradict
their views.
So the most commercially successful
movies generally avoid so much
controversy that nobody pays to see the
movie.
In other words,
commercially successful movies or a
commentary on what the popular beliefs
were at the time of its making.
Of course,
there are plenty of thought provoking
society critiquing movies out there,
but we certainly don't see them topping
the box office.
So where do the Disney princesses fit
into this?
Disney produces some of the most popular
films of all time with 13 of the 25
highest grossing films in history from
The Walt Disney Corporation,
the Disney princess films,
or some of their most successful.
Let's take a look at how Disney films
can form with the societies they were
made in snow white takes place in
Germany in the 15 hundreds but it's very
much a portrayal of life for women in
America when it was made in 1937 women
at this time,
we're taught that their place was in the
home and snow white is a perfect
representation of that view.
For her,
a home is the only safe place.
The outside world is scary.
Her safety is in a house where she fees,
cooks and cleans for others and her life
is eventually saved by a man.
Snow white is more telling a description
of the societal perceptions of women at
that time been any textbook through
fiction.
We get a taste of reality area reflects
society's portrayal of women during the
creation of the little mermaid.
In 1989 America has accepted the
deviation from the nuclear family and a
woman's role outside of the home area
leaves her home.
The ocean inserts for her destiny,
but what does she in search for?
A man,
1989 America still believes a woman's
main goal is to find a husband and start
a family.
Society has not yet reached the
milestone of seeing women independent of
a man.
And that is reflected in the popular
cinema of that era.
Maretta and brave show society's current
view of winning.
She is fierce,
independent,
and doesn't need a man.
In fact,
she outperforms other men in her world,
in our society.
We now recognize women can do anything a
Manton do and don't need men in their
lives to be happy.
Women can now choose their own faith.
When you see a film,
it may take place in the past or the
distant future.
But the film has always subtly
commenting about the society.
It was maiden.
Wally is about a future where humans had
to escape an inhabitable planets.
But it's really a commentary about how
we mistreat the environment today,
who long it takes place in ancient
China.
But it's about how masculine qualities
are not exclusive to men in our current
society.
So here's a question.
Films are influenced by society's views,
but can society's views be influenced by
film?
They reach such a wide audience and can
provide such powerful messages that they
change society's views in radical ways.
Like when jaws led to a huge drop in
beach tourism when men started forming
their own fight clubs after fight club
or when a movie inspires some
southerners to bring back the KKK.
Philadelphia is such an important film
because it was the first production to
portray on man with the HIV virus and it
was a major inspiration for the founding
of an international AIDS Awareness
Association in 1997 Philadelphia touch
the hearts of Americans and brought an
awareness to the struggles of the
disease.
In a way,
a simple awareness campaign never could
have.
What makes Disney princesses so
important is that they're marketed
towards families and especially
children,
children specifically.
Girls idolize these princesses.
They dress up like them,
they mimic them.
They act just like them.
Don't we want to raise girls who become
women with strong views of themselves.
If Disney princesses presented meaning
domesticating values for women,
then women will become that through
mimicking that behavior.
Disney princesses shaped the character
of the children that watch because girls
want to be the princesses they see on
screen.
So what characters should we show them?
Thanks for watching.